[Musique]
alors qu'il a été à nouveau incarcéré au
mois de septembre on a appris la semaine
dernière la libération de Christian
Quesada après avoir passé 22 jours
supplémentaires en détention
l'annonce de sa libération avait alors
fait vivement réagir mercredi dernier
sur notre plateau moi je suis choqué
qu'il soit en liberté pour moi il n'a
rien à faire dehors car ce nom certains
chroniqueurs Christian Quesada montré de
compassion envers ses victimes présumées
non seulement minimise l'effet mais pas
un mot d'excuse pour les victimes ce
soir l'avocat de Christian Quesada nous
livre sa contre-attaque pour la première
fois à la télévision
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous merci beaucoup
Maître Philippe Capsi avocate Christian
Quesada la semaine dernière question qui
est celle-là est donc de nouveau sortie
de prison après un mois derrière les
barreaux car il n'avait pas respecté les
conditions de sa liberté conditionnelle
pourquoi il ne restait qu'un seul mot
merci bonsoir merci alors il s'agit pas
d'une révocation d'une libération
conditionnelle mais de suivi
socio-judiciaire il y a une petite
différence
ce Suisse socio-judiciaire a été mis à
exécution auteur de moi parce que tout
simplement il était dans l'incapacité
d'honorer l'une des obligations qui lui
était imposée celle de travailler et
donc ça a été une sorte de rappel à
l'ordre que le juge de l'application des
peines a voulu lui imposer très bien
alors il y a ici que deux ans de prison
alors qu'il était condamné à trois oui
ça c'est l'application classique du
crédit de réduction de peine automatique
3 mois la première année deux mois les
années qui suivent ajouté à ça le crédit
de réduction de peine supplémentaire ça
ramène la peine de 3 à 2 ans alors la
question que tout le monde se pose ici
une série qu'on en parlait c'est que
vous disiez Gilles que Christian
quesanna avait l'obligation de trouver
du travail de chercher du travail c'est
ce qui me sidère moi c'est que il le
savait très bien il devait où se former
ou travailler pourquoi est-ce qu'il n'a
fait ni l'un ni l'autre maître
il fait un peu découragé il faut le dire
aussi il a fait un certain nombre de
démarches pour rechercher du travail
parce que se former à 58 ans c'est un
peu désespéré il a fait un certain
nombre de démarches avec le soutien de
son SPIP et puis il a à chaque fois
refusé échouer parce que effectivement
quand on tape sur Google Christian et
bien on tombe immédiatement sur son
actualité judiciaire et vous conviendrez
que c'est pas facile pour trouver du
travail lorsqu'on a une telle actualité
donc il a effectué il a fait des
démarches de s'inscrire à Pôle emploi il
a fait un certain nombre de démarches
pour du travail en tant que
téléconseiller et puis il a été reçu à
des entretiens d'embauche qui n'ont
jamais abouti et il faut le reconnaître
donc il y a des gens c'est incroyable ça
20h57 on en direct il y a des gens ils
ont reçu donc question qui est là pour
des entretiens d'embauche c'est fou
quand même c'est vrai que ils ont que
qualité la réaction des gens qui l'ont
reçu parce que c'est vrai que c'est
curieusement il a une réelle notoriété
mais je dois dire que par exemple moi je
ne le connaissais pas donc il a une
notoriété mais qui est assez ciblée et
donc dans le milieu du travail y compris
et peut-être surtout à Perpignan
lorsqu'on fait cette démarche là on
reçoit Christian Quesada mais on connaît
pas son actualité judiciaire qui pour la
petite histoire est relativement
ancienne puisque ça condamnation remonte
à 2020 mais quand on fait cette démarche
là et comme tout employeur on tape
Christian et on arrive à Christian
Quesada très vite avant Christian Dior
avant Christian Clavier c'est vrai avant
Christian Bale on tombe sur Christian
Quesada et d'ailleurs alors il y a
beaucoup de gens qui réagissent qui
disent c'est fou l'avocat de Christian
Quesada en exclusivité dans TPMP c'est
la première fois que vous vous exprimez
question qui est salée est au cœur du
scandale depuis son arrestation 2019 il
a il est condamne à 3 ans de prison
comme on l'a dit il en fera deux
corruption de mineurs et des tensions et
des fusions d'image pédopornographiques
est-ce que Christian Quesada réalise la
gravité des faits ou pas
parce qu'on a l'impression quand on
l'entend notamment dans ces audios que
pas trop il minimise à chaque fois
plutôt c'est un homme extrêmement
intelligent
et puis là évidemment le défaut de ses
qualités c'est-à-dire quand on est très
intelligent on a vite fait de tomber
dans l'excès de la confiance et c'est
peut-être aussi le premier défaut de
Christian Quesada il a eu un second
défaut c'est de ne pas accepter d'être
assisté devant le tribunal correctionnel
le Bourg-en-Bresse justement
il est arrivé sans avocat qui est la
révoqué tout de suite et il s'est
défendu sans avocat alors c'était à huis
clos bon peut-être que c'était possible
mais en tout cas il sait pas très bien
défendu et puis ensuite c'est lui qui
vous a sollicité mettre après absolument
oui parce qu'il s'est rendu compte que
ça n'allait pas sans arrêt
ce que je veux dire c'est que devant un
tribunal correctionnel aussi intelligent
souhaitons on ne peut pas se défendre
c'est impossible on manque du recul on
manque de l'expérience on manque de
psychologie on manque de beaucoup trop
de choses pour obtenir le meilleur
résultat je pense que ça il a compris
effectivement quand il a été vous le
savez donc convoqué devant le juge de
l'application des peines pour une
éventuelle mise à exécution de cette
de ce Suisse socio-judiciaire la famille
a fait la démarche de l'assister parce
que la leçon était déjà reçue alors
est-ce qu'il reconnaît les c'est
Christian je crois qu'il a toujours
reconnu les faits il y a eu jamais de
difficultés
mais alors
c'est le souci lorsqu'on se défend
soi-même c'est-à-dire que quand on est
soi-même mis en cause et qu'on essaye de
se défendre on va évidemment
immédiatement être taxé de minimiser
l'effet si c'est un défenseur qui le
fait pour vous ça passe beaucoup mieux
tout de suite
quels sont les charges exactes qui ont
été retenues contre Christian Quesada
alors que ce soit bien clair je ne
connais pas le fond de ce dossier qui
lui a valu cette convention par le
tribunal correction de Bourg-en-Bresse
en 2020
vous les avez rappelé les chefs de
poursuite ils ont été retenus ce sont
des faits de 2017 de 2017 qui nous
ramène donc très loin en arrière qui ne
correspond pas vraiment il faut le dire
à la réelle actualité de Christian
Quesada la réelle actualité de Christian
Quesada c'est ce suivi socio-judiciaire
qui a présenté une difficulté cette
obligation de travailler toutes les
autres ont été scrupuleusement
respectées l'interdiction d'entrer en
contact avec les victimes se soigner
indemniser les victimes
ne pas diffuser peuvent s'exprimer sur
les infractions qui lui ont été
reprochées tout ça a été scrupuleusement
respecté reste et c'est votre actualité
pardon cette obligation de travailler
alors il a pris comme on l'a dit un
avocat commis d'office à la base Gilles
il souhaitait se défendre tout seul
en parlant très vertement de son avocat
d'ailleurs dans le si c'est compliqué
d'être l'avocat de Christian qui est là
à moi j'ai rencontré strictement aucune
difficulté je l'ai rencontré à trois
reprises le contact a été normal j'ai
immédiatement rencontré quelqu'un
déminemment intelligent vous le
connaissez pas non Savi pas qui c'était
non pas du tout non vraiment quand vous
avez eu l'affaire en le dossier vous
êtes dit c'est mon entourage qui m'a
fait comprendre que ce monsieur avait
gagné un certain nombre de jeux
télévisés
c'est cette vraie intelligence c'est pas
qu'une accumulation de connaissance
c'est une aptitude à raisonner c'est un
homme intelligent qui sait très bien
qu'il a fait qui sait très bien
l'analysé qui s'est en comprendre même
les
tenants et les aboutissants le mécanisme
de son passage à l'acte il n'a rien à
comprendre de plus que ce qu'il a déjà
lui
analyséa après n'allez pas trop vite
s'il vous plaît juste là pour l'instant
qu'est-ce qui vous a dit Christian
Quesada quand il vous a vu la première
fois
alors je le rencontre à la maison
d'arrêt effectivement on fait
connaissance parce que je ne le
connaissais pas il
m'explique sa situation c'est à dire ce
mandat d'amener devant un juge de
l'application des peines un 26 septembre
vous dites vous lui reconnaissez pas
avant ça m'intéresse pas et puis moi
j'ai ma méthode de travail c'est-à-dire
que rapidement je cible mon
interlocuteur j'ai mes questions
habituelles et je cible très rapidement
à qui j'ai à faire et et au niveau de
l'état civil au niveau de l'intelligence
et au niveau de son aptitude à raisonner
et là j'ai compris que j'avais à faire
quelqu'un d'intelligent et il vous a dit
quoi
vous avez dit défendez moi et vous a dit
pas spécialement c'est pas quelqu'un qui
est dans une démarche jusqu'au-boutiste
de se défendre de s'en sortir c'est pas
ça c'est quelqu'un de plutôt résigné et
et et c'est quelqu'un qui
cherche avec moi à comprendre ce qui se
passe parce qu'il a pas eu accès au
dossier il comprend un peu que c'est
cette obligation de travail qui lui fait
défaut rapidement on consulte le dossier
je retourne le voir pour le préparer
puis on comprend que ça n'est que ça ça
n'est que ça alors c'est quel est le
profil psychologique de votre client de
Christian Quesada
c'est un homme très intelligent c'est un
homme que tout le monde de s'accorde à
dire plutôt égocentré c'est-à-dire qu'il
est replié sur lui-même c'est à dire que
il est centré sur lui-même c'est-à-dire
que sa personne compte et elle est
importante pour lui mais bon c'est aussi
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure le
défaut de ses qualités à quoi vous avez
vu ça qu'il était extrêmement centré sur
lui c'est un trait de caractère qui
ressort rapidement parce que il a envie
de tout comprendre de tout maîtriser il
faut le dire aussi et et en quelque part
c'est sa vie aussi donc c'est aussi
compréhensible
je sais qu'il y a des personnes qui
disent c'est vrai qu'ils regardent tout
ce qui se fait sur lui il a même appelé
le bureau de Guillaume Genton pour pour
témoigner il veut pourquoi il veut
exister il veut encore exister
médiatiquement
je sais pas ce qui se passe concrètement
dans sa tête mais je me mets peut-être à
sa place et à la vôtre si un jour c'est
un notoriété s'arrête que vous descendez
quelque part pas loin des enfers ou de
l'enfer et est-ce que vous cherchez pas
quelque part à vous
à ce qui vous reste c'est à dire c'est
une notoriété même si aujourd'hui elle
le dessert mais ça mais aujourd'hui vous
disiez la série que je sais que vous
avez mis aujourd'hui Christian Quesada
il a besoin aussi d'avoir une notoriété
c'est ça aussi ils sont ça sa raison de
vivre
je suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr qu'il
cherche absolument encore à exister sur
le plan médiatique j'en suis pas certain
et je l'appelle Guillaume Genton il veut
il veut participer alors je crois que
c'est Monsieur Garnier qui l'appelle à
l'occasion d'un enregistrement
téléphonique bien sûr et c'est quelque
part pour échanger sur alors peut-être
qu'il y a une démarche ambiguë je peux
pas complètement la contester mais très
sincèrement moi ce que j'ai ressenti
c'est une réelle volonté dans nos
limaces parce que c'est anonymat
aujourd'hui il a besoin pour s'insérer
et repartir aujourd'hui question que
c'est vous parlez énormément avec lui
vous aimez échanger avec lui j'ai pris
du temps pour échanger et je dois dire
que j'ai pris du plaisir à échanger avec
lui parce que les changer nourri les
riches et il est pas seulement dans
l'étalage de ses connaissances il y a
une reine je l'ai dit aptitude à
raisonner on sent qu'il vous a reconnu
c'est tellement rare que oui
d'abord parce que dans le cas de son
Suisse aussi judiciaire il a lui
l'interdiction de parler des infractions
pour lesquelles il a été condamné alors
ce qui lui est son avocat alors à son
avocat
ensuite est-ce qu'il est réellement
utile aujourd'hui
clairement après les faits vous pensez
le dossier en 2020 vous dites que ça
fait super longtemps impression que
c'est le moyen-âge ça fait que deux ans
2017 on a l'impression aussi que c'est
le moyen-âge ça fait que 5 ans ce serait
important peut-être d'ouvrir ce dossier
2017-2020 si vous êtes son avocat et si
vous y avez le droit moi je connais pas
pour pouvoir justement arrêter de nous
parler de lui comme si c'est un super
héros c'est un mec qui regarde c'est un
mec qui regarde des enfants dans des
ordinateurs c'est
je vais pas dire le mot parce que si je
veux dire c'est une ordure c'est une
ordure Christian Quesada vous êtes en
train de me faire croire que ces gens
pour le Belmondo
de pas ouvrir le dossier en 2020 je
respecte votre foi mais je respecte
aussi beaucoup ce que vous voulez dire
c'est juste injurieux mais c'est pas
utile de mon point de départ pour vous
dire que le dossier il a été refermé par
cette condamnation du tribunal
correction de Bourg-en-Bresse en 2020
alors moi je veux bien le rouvrir à
l'infini mais qu'est-ce qu'on va
apporter de plus que ce qu'a dit un
tribunal correctionnel de manière
aujourd'hui définitive à mon avis
dans la société
là on est sur le fait c'est vrai que on
a l'impression qu'il faut facilement
discutablement alors je dois et vous
avez raison ne pas réduire Christian
Quesada à cette intelligence parce que
il a effectivement c'est ce que vous
avez fait un peu mettre je m'en excuse
mais ce que je veux vous dire par là
c'est que aujourd'hui c'est un tout
c'est à dire que c'est cette
intelligence que je rappelle c'est aussi
ces passages à l'acte qui ont été
sanctionnés par un tribunal
correctionnel et c'est effectivement à
l'image de sa vie c'est à dire des
cycles avec des phases hautes et des
phases basses et là ce que je vous
demande de retenir c'est que il est dans
une phase d'ascension c'est-à-dire que
il a eu à toucher le bas c'est un
discutable et là tu es en train de
remonter alors justement c'est la
question que vous pose depuis deux
heures tout le monde vous la pose mais
c'est question sur laquelle on voulait
revenir aujourd'hui vous qui avez
énormément discuté avec lui est-ce que
vous pensez qui ne qui fera plus ce
qu'il a fait avant ou bien vous n'y
croyez pas du tout vous pensez qu'il
peut récidiver
moi je suis
je suis j'ai eu accès au dossier j'ai
constaté que cette obligation de suivre
des soins elle avait été non seulement
respectée mais sur investi nous dit
l'expert psychiatre qui coordonne
justement cette obligation de soins
cette expert psychiatre nous dit de lui
que c'est quelqu'un pardon madame de
particulièrement intelligent qui suit
scrupuleusement cette obligation qui est
dans l'échange et qui et qui joue le jeu
de cette obligation de soins donc si
vous voulez je suis pas moi psychiatre
je suis pas objectif mais je peux vous
dire que cette obligation là elle est
non seulement respectée mais sur investi
et la conscience d'être malade alors il
est surtout conscient qu'il a été
condamné à une obligation de soins il
avait déjà perdu
est-ce qu'il est conscient d'être un
homme malade on est malade quand on a
fait ce qu'il a fait
je suis pas psychiatre vous êtes quoi
alors je suis avocat mais d'après
je suis psychiatre d'après le rapport
vous nous dites que les psychiatres
disent qu'il est l'évolution est
favorable l'évolution favorable le suivi
est sur investi et aujourd'hui ce qui
pose question c'est son insertion par le
travail il y avait des j'ai pas du tout
aujourd'hui le risque de récidive parce
que il ne suivrait pas cette obligation
de soi c'est à dire qu'on peut le
laisser aller dans la société
on fait juste Guillaume Genton et après
pour ce qui soit payé aujourd'hui
Castaldi quoi en question
non moi Maître je vous respecte beaucoup
vous faites votre travail mais je suis
consterné j'hallucine de ce que j'en
pense ce soir vous dites que Raymond est
injurieux quand il dit que Christian
Quesada est une ordure moi je vais pas
être un jour et je vais être factuel
Christian quai dada c'est un pédophile
c'est un pédophile en fait et vous
passez votre temps à vous attaquer à
ceux qui dénoncent donc TPMP les
produits les chroniqueurs la production
et pourquoi on s'intéresse pas à ce qui
est dénoncé pourquoi on s'intéresse pas
à la corruption de mineurs aux photos ou
viol d'enfant de moins de 10 ans
à ses convocations qui ont été données à
des jeunes filles mineures tout ce qu'il
y avait sur son ordinateur moi je suis
désolé faire de la peine à Christian
Quesada j'en ai rien à faire mais ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la peine de ses
victimes qui sont pour certaines
traumatisées à vie et vous vous êtes là
nous dire qu'il est intelligent c'est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement brillant pardon
on s'en fout me mettre mais
vous en prenez plein la tête là non non
mais c'est votre travail
mais c'est pas compliqué c'est le jeu
je comprends là aussi ce que vous
soutenez mais si vous voulez je vais pas
revenir en arrière le procès il est fait
on va pas le refaire et encore moins ici
l'actualité aujourd'hui c'est la
personne c'est ça qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il est intelligent
oui est-ce qu'il est en capacité de
récidiver ça c'est ça la vraie question
là aujourd'hui ce qu'on vous dit c'est
que le cadre qu'on lui a imposé que la
justice lui imposé ce suivi
socio-judiciaire donne satisfaction à
part cette obligation de travailler
c'est ça pose problème alors après
on peut évidemment comme vous pensez ce
que vous pensez et je suis obligé de le
respecter mais c'est plus l'actualité
les filles ils ont été jugés pantoufles
en fait vous réponse me font peur mais
pas particulièrement sur cette affaire
ça montre en fait qu'on relâche des gens
même vous même les psychiatres les gens
qui sont qui le suivent ne savent pas du
tout s'il va récidiver ou pas vous jeter
dans la nature des gens qui vont à
nouveau être sans doute dangereux pour
nos enfants et là vous êtes vraiment le
voilà vous nous expliquez ça
tranquillement vous nous montrez la
puissance de la justice le laxisme même
l'impuissance moi je pense il y a une
jeune fille qui témoignait dans le noir
dans le documentaire de Guillaume qui
disait qu'en fait ça ne sert à rien de
le mettre en prison de le faire sortir
de le remettre c'est quelqu'un qu'il
faut vraiment soigner et guérir pour
l'instant apparemment personne ne peut
dire si les guéri et on pense plutôt
qu'il ne l'est pas mais il est dans la
nature voilà et ça moi ça me fait très
très peur parce qu'il y en a beaucoup
moins connus mais beaucoup mais
qu'est-ce que vous dites
qu'est-ce que je réponds je lui réponds
que la justice est passée sur ces faits
la justice est passée on peut pas
aujourd'hui y revenir indéfiniment et
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez qui reste
définitivement incarcéré pour des faits
pour des faits de corruption de mineurs
et de détention d'image
pédopornographiques je le rappelle il y
a pas de passage à l'acte il y a pas de
passage à l'acte alors c'est déjà très
grave ce qui s'est passé c'est même
contrats et tout ça c'est pas des
passages à l'acte de lui mais c'est tout
un réseau excusez-moi
manipulé en fait on en a parlé beaucoup
ici c'est un grand manipulateur et quand
vous êtes là vous le défendez parce que
vous êtes avocat mais vous êtes manipulé
par lui c'est son avocat aussi
vous êtes fan de de l'animation
effectivement moi ça m'inquiète non mais
c'est son avocat comme on a dit après
c'est vrai que voilà c'est c'est pas
défendu par ton avocate tu es défendu
par personne voilà en tout cas tu seras
c'est bon tu as parlé